[Music]
[Laughter]
we decided to do a sidetrack show today
because i mean not a drunken one because
you know it's only three o'clock in the
afternoon we're drunk but we're not that
bad yeah
but it's like you know because well we
didn't really have time to watch any
movies
yeah um we couldn't really think of any
food to talk about particularly because
we've been like so busy
we had to go to the show we had to go
start a nice show last year yeah we were
gonna show last night and then uh
tomorrow we have to go to uh
tomorrow so we gotta pack schedule for
right now yeah
but um yeah yeah we didn't see anything
yeah tonight we're gonna watch terror
train though yeah we're gonna review
that for uh
friday it's up on shutter so if you guys
want to go see terror train
got jamie lee curtis i remember when i
was a kid man i liked it
yeah it's like a slasher yeah train kind
of yeah it was canadian i think wasn't
it it is yeah
yeah yeah i don't think it had much gore
in it it was i don't remember i haven't
seen it in a really long time so i'm
kind of interested to
that was the one that won the poll so
for the movie retrospective so that's
what we're gonna do i liked it as a kid
i thought it was just
i just feel just scary enough i could
watch it and you know what i mean get
scared out of it when i was a kid
but i don't think it had any gore which
i think made it easier for me to watch
okay i didn't have to like get a squint
or anything when something would happen
oh no see there's a [ __ ] funny thing
about friday the 13th stuff
i was always squinting when the [ __ ]
somebody was getting killed
i wasn't quite sure what it looked like
which i think kind of made you imagine
the gore a lot worse than it actually
was it wasn't until like
having it play on [ __ ] cable tv
like [ __ ] 20 times over a summer it
would probably took me most of that
summer until where i could [ __ ]
saw every frame of the movie yeah yeah
because they were cueing you through the
damn
soundtrack when somebody was going to
get killed and you knew already
because you know you was like on the
fourth viewing
but i think when it actually i think a
lot of that time i was blinking or
flinching you know when the [ __ ] was
going on and i'd catch
little bits of it and try to have to
piece it together
it's not even really that gory no it was
not as gory as you think it is
the first couple friday the 13th right
movies like for the reputation that they
have they're super not gory
yeah like especially nowadays like
because after all the torture porn [ __ ]
happened and now it's like [ __ ] yeah
now shit's way gory here
yeah back then but back then nobody's
like oh friday the 13th well i think i
think part of the deal was is that
i mean if if you're living somewhere in
a dab apartment building in new york
city
that movie doesn't mean the same thing
as it would to a person like me who was
in mississippi
where if you looked outside your down
window at night there was no other house
lights
it's just woods out there and then there
was jason so jason
could be out there with this machete
waving at you yeah this is for you
yeah so i think living in a rural
environment made it a lot more intense
zach asked out of curiosity what's your
favorite non-horror movie
oh man ooh okay well
does mulholland drive count as a horror
movie if not than that
but if if it does count as a horror
movie
hmm clockwork orange amadeus
um i don't know
i mean amadeus definitely isn't a horror
movie tila's in the comment section with
a new uh photograph
of somebody else probably she has not
verified that that is her in those
photos she's just
you know i'm trying to keep it on the
downloads
she says thanks so much for recommending
time after time i watched it last night
and loved it
who said that tila oh yeah yeah that is
a great [ __ ] movie i love that movie
so much i thought
that movie was on cable every [ __ ]
hour
it seemed like back in the early 80s and
i saw it probably 400 times and every
time like you'd be
scrolling through the channels and it
would be on i would just sit and watch
it again yeah
it was one of those kind of movies so i
think i have it memorized at this point
i've seen it so many times
jack the ripper meets [ __ ] ace g
wells that's a good that's good it's a
great [ __ ] premise
it's a great premise and i just and i
love the acting in it i just love
everything about it
i love that [ __ ] movie yeah if you
like that one check out somewhere in
time
that's a good one too christopher reeves
yeah he time travels back to the past
to see a woman he falls in love with she
was just a famous actress he saw
he found a fit a photograph over and
he's able to kind of like
do some kind of weird transcendental
meditation and he slips off into the
past and meet her
yeah yeah yeah that's pretty good zac
asks would you count there will be blood
as a horror movie because it may as well
be in my mind
i don't know if i well i don't know
it's kind of like a horror movie yeah
that's like
you know i need to see that again i saw
that in the theater when it came out and
i remember really liked it
for me best non-horror movie would have
been either road warrior or [ __ ] fury
road
he was just watching those yesterday
yeah i could hear it across the house
yeah
i heard witness
[Music]
i was like oh he's watching fury road
again yeah
all those dudes committing suicide so
they can go to kamikazes
i have a way to get involved oh my god i
love that movie yeah
well they were gonna live long anyway i
just like i could that's another movie
that i could watch over and
and over just like the shining yeah if
you'd asked me like i said when you were
in there watching fury road i was
like oh i kind of want to sit down and
watch it again but i don't know what i
gotta do
well what happens with fury road is that
you just see more and more of it
and you see more and more stuff that you
missed the more you watch it
like guys in the background doing things
that you didn't see before or
the way a certain guy was dressed who
ended up like remember the pole cats who
were yeah
all the big poles and they were ended up
they were throwing them onto the
tops of the vehicles you'd see one's in
the background trying to do stuff
you know but can get you know they'd
land and come off and then uh get ready
to fight and then
some of them were trying to figure out
how to [ __ ] um uh disconnect certain
parts of the vehicle to get the vehicle
to stop
and it's it's happening so fast i mean
it's a visual feast
and like you said there's just always
something interesting [ __ ] going on in
the background it's like really
immersive
yeah and then all the vehicles they get
destroyed you catch snippets of in the
back the damn vehicle car carrier that
they had
was getting more and more full and it
had the wrecks of the vehicles that
wrecked
so they were picking all those racks up
they didn't leave them out in the desert
well yeah that's like pieces you can use
that for other [ __ ]
yeah and then there was a bunch of
infantry guys holding on to the [ __ ]
v
the the car carrier too they were they
were loaded up in it
so not just cars but guys in it yeah
replacements so as you took casualties
you had
replacement troops replacement guys yeah
yeah
it's just like you know that's it's like
a brilliant movie it's one of the best
movies
that we've seen recently yeah road
warrior is good too yeah
somebody said what about thunderdome i
thought i talked about thunderdome
thunderdome's okay
that's all right it's okay it's not a
bad movie uh it's the weakest out of all
of them but it's not bad
it's got dialogue problems it could have
been fixed and edit
the dialogue and some of the some of the
score
it is not really what should be in a
movie like that
that you could tell they're trying to
take that movie kind of mainstream
hollywood
and mad max was never intended to be
mainstream hollywood it was the vision
of one man
and uh i even liked the first one and
the first one was his first attempt you
know was it him george miller yeah
george miller's first attempt and it has
problems
but not bad problems not at all it's
just
the edit is not quite as smooth uh there
are parts in there that
really shouldn't be in there like some
romance scenes between max and his wife
that's not really
you don't really need that i think it
slowed down the pace of the movie
or you didn't need them to be that long
they could have
cut them off real short because you're
talking about an action movie you don't
need a love scene in it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] no don't need it xana
chick flick
nope get out of here with that [ __ ]
no well no if you're going to have a
love scene it could only just be a few
seconds to let
the audience know that it did happen
yeah it doesn't have to
to dwell on it he loves her okay move on
because the man the main uh the maiden
audience is males
and it's fast-paced movie you know what
i mean i want to get bogged down in this
[ __ ] sentimental [ __ ]
we know we know he's hitting yeah
and he's he's he's he's romantically
involved
okay we don't need to like wallow around
on
how much he's into we already know
okay yeah
it just slows the movie down you you
know you're waiting for more action and
it also
uh the um it kind of had a couple of
minutes like sentimental music which
kind of changes the tone of the movie it
shouldn't have gone that way
you know what i mean just like okay we
know what you're doing but he was doing
that because they did that in other
movies
yeah he's not doing it the way he wants
it he's doing the way he he did it the
way he thought it had to be done i think
yeah you know he could have been a
little more innovative when that because
he never did it again
yeah never did that again yeah i think i
think he realized that was a mistake
but uh no mad max one could really be
enhanced with a tighter edit
yeah i agree yeah i had for actually i
hadn't seen it for a long time and then
when i re-watched it i'd forgotten
how how it had like a lot of scenes like
that yeah you know because i think i was
getting it confused with the road
warrior
um zach is talking about a movie called
uh clute with jane fonda i remember that
one i remember liking that one a lot
actually i have to like watch that again
um mr roboto says jenny how about an
apocalypse chick flick
um i have seen a couple like that i'm
not a big chick flick person
you know i don't really like i don't
really like
romance movies i don't really like
there's a couple more comments that are
good
there's a couple that are good but it's
not usually my go-to
because i just i don't know i don't like
them but um
tila said one of her favorite movies of
all time would be all about eve ooh
that's a good one
whatever happened to baby jane uh xanada
says do a retrospective on taxi driver
yeah we probably should
whatever happened baby jane that was a
[ __ ] trippy old black and white movie
yeah i like that yeah one sister had the
other sister [ __ ]
it was kind of like did she feed her a
rat better a [ __ ] rat
cooked rat i think he fed her she found
her a [ __ ] cat too didn't she try to
later on over her pet cat yeah
it's been last time i thought yeah she's
kind of like torture and her sister
who's now an invalid and it's because
what was it
she was an ex-star and yeah the other
one
never made it and she kind of like it's
kind of like uh
that stephen king story what was it
where uh the woman [ __ ]
trap [ __ ] captured her favorite
author misery
like misery kind of that's how i
remembered it but it's been a long time
i've seen it
maybe we're seeing it phil asked what
was your favorite old black and white
movie the haunting from 1963
that was creepy yeah i love that movie
that's probably one of my favorite
horror movies of all time
and the novel is fantastic also i think
my favorite black and white movie would
have been um
the loved one yeah it was a [ __ ]
trippy ass movie yeah that was a good
one i mean doctor strangelove if you're
gonna talk about like old
like you know i really really like a lot
of old actually i just did i just
recorded a review
for one it's gonna go up when is it
going up next saturday probably
um of a movie that i had never heard of
before
shutter just added it not too long again
came out in 1961 it was called night
tide
and it was dennis hopper's first
starring role about a dude that starts
dating a girl that maybe is a
mermaid yeah um but yeah i think
that's super cool now that you mentioned
dr strangelove i think i had to put that
above the loved one
yeah that's a better movie i mean that's
a brilliant [ __ ] yeah they're both
good though they're both kind of similar
in yeah i love those old black and white
movies man
i love silent movies too one of my
favorite silent movies was [ __ ]
the hands of orlak yeah i love that [ __ ]
yeah yeah see if you haven't seen dr
strangelove that's one you should see
it's got um uh peter sellers in it
um slim pickens is in it uh
james jones is in a young james earl
jones yeah yeah he plays one of the
[ __ ] b-52 bomber crewmen i think he
was the bomb or deer wouldn't he
bomber the navigator one of the two
gonna drop a damn atomic bomb on the
russians
we're going toe-to-toe with the ruskies
of nuclear combat
he got his [ __ ] puts his helmet away
and puts his cowboy head on [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] russians were throwing
everything at him and so were the
americans trying to stop that bomber
because it was a they sent them this
they they gave him the code accidentally
a
general went rogue an air force general
went rogue and just launched on the
on the launch the bombers on on uh
on the russians on the soviet union by
accident wasn't approved
and just that one bomber going through
all that [ __ ] to drop the bomb
they just dropped one bomb it's like a
funny
and it and they didn't they didn't even
get to the primary target the secondary
target
it was just an alternate target it was
just a weather station
wasn't it something like that like i
said it's been a long time yeah it was
just a [ __ ]
a nothing target but they didn't know it
the russians had a damn doomsday device
that would blow up and destroy the whole
earth if
if you if you dropped an atomic bomb on
them
good movie it is yeah it's really good
um
[Music]
fourth throwdown asked if we had seen
sorcerer was that like the william
friedkin one
i think i saw it but it's been a long
time and i don't remember anything about
it so that's another one that i have to
resee
uh zach said uh fatal attraction is top
10 for me
i love how it starts out like a regular
sex thriller but kind of turns into a
drama or character study yeah that is
also a great movie
yeah t it's a doctor strangers peter
sellers he plays at least
three roles i think he plays four roles
in the movie
at different different roles and it's
stanley kubrick
so that's one you got to see it's really
good
yeah definitely yeah and a lot of it's
kind of a lot of it was based in truth
you know the little secret plans and
[ __ ] that they had up norad and
or you know [ __ ] nuclear bomber
command where they did [ __ ] and [ __ ]
how they were they the backup they had
all these backup plans the the uh
the the american leadership could go
underground and live for decades
they even had a secret hotel that would
do that they had another had a nuclear
fallout shelter underneath it
but they retired it because they built a
better one and we don't know we don't
know what to have
it's my it's my opinion and my belief
based on things that i saw
in service and just think the rumors and
[ __ ] that i've seen on television mixed
in with it
there's old mine shafts that have been
sold off to the to the government
federal government
that we're just [ __ ] extensive just
thousands and thousands and thousands of
miles of [ __ ] mines and
tunnels underneath the united states
they're doing something with them
there's stuff down there they're stuffed
there's stuff down there some kind of
stuff
there was a [ __ ] some kind of a
sodium mine and it was underneath the
gulf of mexico you got into it i think
from louisiana and it went way
underneath the ocean
and down in there i think the sodium is
what they were digging up something that
you used in making
aluminum but it's abandoned now
it i saw a program they went in there
and there's a whole
1950s underground
town in there with paved streets
parking lots street lights
[ __ ] uh uh traffic lights like red
you know stop lights and traffic lights
and apartment buildings apartment
complexes and
underground uh football fields and
baseball fields
because at one time that that company
had thousands and thousands of miners
living in there
so they had a whole town for them
underneath the underneath it
and if you were walking just they were
walking around in it
filming it and it was like you were
walking around outside at night you
didn't had no idea you were in a mine
but they just cleared out so much that's
pretty cool i would totally live down
there
yeah and the ceiling because they were
kind of strip mining in there the floor
got dropped and dropped and dropped
until the ceiling was [ __ ] you know
hundreds and hundreds of feet above you
and so you couldn't see the ceiling it
just looked like a
starless night and uh you know i had an
elevator that would take you down there
you could take whole vehicles
and i tried to find it again i couldn't
find it
it was something i saw on the history
channel and uh
they have whole parking lots of cars
abandoned underneath there
they never they brought cars and
vehicles
to the mine but they never got any of
them out as they broke and went obsolete
they just threw them into the corner or
just parked them in parking lots and
left them there let's leave it
they just left them it wasn't worth it
taking it out well yeah be too expensive
to get them out of there down here's the
point and there's
trucks going all the way back to the 50s
just parked in
underneath there and it's just covered
in dust and they go into the apartment
complexes and it was just
spooky as [ __ ] there's no power they
were going in there just the flashlights
and stuff
all the beds were made you still had
clean dishes put up in the
it was like they were going to come back
any minute the calendars were still up
spooky yeah there was something we could
still get in there down there i could
i could totally go live down there i
could squat nobody would even know i was
down
at the time they made the program the
time they made the program
uh the company the company that owned
the mine still owned it it was just
closed
they let them down in there but nobody
some of those places people hadn't been
there since the 80s interesting and they
were doing this in the uh
early 2000s is when that program came
out they hadn't been there since the 80s
spooky and there were houses too not
just apartment buildings but houses
like 80s 1980s looking houses
on streets like in a neighborhood but it
was weird it was underground
and they were just going into these
random houses they were they were open
and everything was just
put away and nice and tidy and
because the people just when the mine
closed down people just kind of packed
up and left
yep because there was still furniture in
there and everything they just took
personal belongings we'll have to find
that
documentary because that sounds like
super cool so it makes you wonder
you would think the governments would
buy up stuff like that
and use them for emergencies and that's
what happens in dr strangelove that they
had some mine chefs
that they could move into in in the
event of a nuclear
war and lived out in there mr roboto
asked how's pookie today
she's good she's sleeping she's sleeping
up in her little
tree that has the little three little
apartments we call her little apartments
she usually sleeps in the top one but
sometimes she sleeps in the middle one
and sometimes there's like a little bowl
she sleeps into and then tila is asking
uh i usually don't like musicals but i
do have faves what's hell's favorite
musicals she says wizard of oz and the
wiz
um yeah i really like greece i really
like
um hedwig and the angry inch rocky
horror picture show
velvet gold mine moulin rouge
um i tend to like newer ones like newer
musicals
as opposed to like older ones i guess
although i like some older ones too i
even like grease too
yeah i know it's a bad movie like i said
i've said before but it's not a guilty
pleasure because i'm not guilty about it
if you don't if you don't like it then
step off
t said she liked uh being there too that
peter sells me this [ __ ] was awesome
i know i love that movie his name
chauncey yeah
child say the girl chelsea would just
yeah chauncey gardner he'd just walk up
to a new black woman and ask for food
tila said i sound much better today yeah
i actually kind of feel i'm a little
still a little bit
congested but i'm pretty good i was kind
of worried because you know when we went
to the show last night
i was like man i don't really want to i
don't want everybody thinking i have the
rona and i'm like sneezing all over
everybody but i actually after i had a
couple beers i
didn't really feel like i had a cold
anymore so much beer
yeah we took the show last night was
really really good we hadn't seen
a starry night live well they hadn't
even played live up here
for two years something like that yeah
and anytime we get to go to will's pub
is good because i love that place
although we walked in there we haven't
been in there for like a couple of years
and everything was like moved around
yeah it was no longer an irish pub
you didn't notice that well yeah i did
notice that but yeah it was no longer an
irish pub it was just more of a
modernized kind of [ __ ]
yeah they moved the bar into the front
room yeah which used to just have
uh pinball machines and stuff like that
in it and then like in the back room
they put like a pool table
and tables and [ __ ] and uh and they have
like a bigger menu now now they have
like cuban sandwiches and
boiled peanuts and all kind of stuff
like that
and i'm sure pretty sure because
remember before like we thought they
didn't have a liquor license but i'm
pretty sure they have one now yeah
because they had like hard liquor but
that we just drank beers though
we were hanging out with starry night
and uh a little boy was [ __ ]
tripping about on he was going off on
boiled peanuts because they got boiled
peanuts here
yes he had to explain to me we go
he's explaining to me like i don't know
we're from miami you know we don't have
boiled peanuts there
no it's because you know south florida
is basically central america and these
guys are all central american descent
you know the starry night is a hispanic
bad then you know expanded gods man and
yeah
kind of like i didn't know he's
explaining to me i said i know man you
guys have been there
longer than the united states has
existed he's like yeah
empire guys like we don't know we don't
know for boiled peanuts yeah although he
was
he was really into him elia was but then
howard was like yeah i didn't care for
him i'm like yeah i'm i'm
i'm tv howard i don't agree yeah i don't
like him either no
no ilia was like man those things are
good you gotta seize them right
yeah you put like an old bay and [ __ ]
like that yeah and another thing too
it's like
we it's funny because the show
i mean the it's open to eight so it was
still it's really weird like to be all
gothed out and to go to will's pub and
it's still daylight outside and be like
drinking and stuff
um sherry mouse was there she was djing
and then so we were there we took the
kids with us and then we were there for
like a really long time before the bands
even started but there was like some
good music and [ __ ]
and then the opening bands um were
called
uh violet silhouette they're from west
palm
in uh west palm beach which is near
miami
and i guess a star united wanted them to
come along and it's like man they were
really really good
yeah i had never heard them before but
they were really good and it was really
nice to see
that a big huge i mean it was a
it was a big turnout i was like
surprised yeah and it was all
like 95 percent like death rock people
yeah which you you don't usually see
them it's all coming out at
momento mori or anything like that
because that's kind of more i guess
that's more like an industrial synth pop
more of a vibe even though it's still
goth people but um
but when you when a starry night plays
that's when you get like all the old
death rock people and all the old kind
of like well you also had like uh kind
of a punk rock couple
in there they had that one girl she was
probably about six foot
four and weighed about 110 pounds and
she had the damn red ziggy stardust
haircut and everything she was looking
pretty cool
yeah she yeah she had a really late 70s
kind of punk rock looking
yeah you know it's funny because it's
like there's tons of like death rocker
people around here but you just don't
see them out that much
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
every now and then like there'll be a
show
and then they all turn up and you're
like where the [ __ ] are you people
normally
yeah the kids were excited because this
was kind of like yeah well this was a
leia's first um
live show she'd never been to one before
so she was like super excited
she's so cute because she's always kind
of like and she was saying this to um
to ilya from a starry night too she was
she was like i thought that
you know she's 18. so she was just kind
of like you know she's all into this
goth and death rock stuff and she was
like i thought i was the only one like
around here that was into it and i'm
like oh honey
i was like well i thought that too but i
thought that back in 1981
[Laughter]
because i'm old but yeah but and i had
probably had more
reason to think that because i grew up
in daytona beach and there actually
weren't that many
cool people that were that kind of [ __ ]
when i was growing up back then there
was a few but not that many
but uh yeah yeah phil says yeah it is
sucky when you go out where the bars are
open all night and then you leave and go
out and the sun kills you
[Laughter]
yeah so um grandpa's is looking he says
he said he didn't understand the uh
the appeal of boiled peanuts yeah they
taste like warm boogers yeah
that's pretty much exactly what they
taste like yeah they don't know to me
they do
there's a bunch of different flavors and
it depends on whether they're hot or
they're cold
and what they've been boiled in but when
i've said it to elia it says yeah it's
kind of like eating beans
and he goes yeah that's what it is yeah
it's like eating beans it's just
instead of they're still in the shell so
you got to take them out of the shell
but they're boiled and they end up kind
of tasting like
black-eyed peas really well they're in i
mean peanuts and beans are in the same
family
so that's not that weird that they taste
like that kind of like crostine
black-eyed
peas and maybe pinto beans it's probably
the closest that they taste like pinto
beans
so it's the seasoning that that's in
them and you know i was just
in the south up north y'all you know
mostly focused on [ __ ] like popcorn
in the south we had so many peanuts
traditionally going all the way back
to the 1800s because peanuts replaced
cotton
uh things changed and you just cut there
was other ways of getting cotton and i
think a lot of the cotton stuff
ended up being overseas and it was
replaced with peanuts
and peanuts could be sold off just on on
a global scale you can even make things
like plastic out of peanuts for a while
you know it's probably all obsolete now
but um
so we just sat around they sat around
listening to the radio and then later on
the television
eating boiled peanuts because they were
everywhere [ __ ] everywhere
just a snack and they were just in the
boil water
you know the basic thing would just be
salt but that's kind of
boring later on when like cajun food
started to become popular in the south
they started using things like zadaran's
crab boil or
um uh like in old bay
or just things that you would boil
seafood in
you know you could you could um
you could put that you could you could
put that in the water
and usually they put them into bags
they'd have the peanuts in one bag
there's like a burlap bag and then you'd
have the shrimp in another burlap bag
and
crawfish and things like potatoes
because the cooking time is different on
them
you'd have potatoes and corn in another
bag and you'd be throwing them into the
same big old boiling pot of water
keeping it separate and
you know since you already got boiling
water throw them peanuts in there it's
just like that
and it comes out oh yeah and it kind of
tasted a little bit like seafood and
that's what they were doing i just
always kind of feel like
i mean i love peanuts i love peanut
butter i'm also team
chunky uh so this is tila said because
zach asked
um and so i just think they're so good
roasted
that why would you boil them it's kind
of like a situation
with some vegetables you know what i
mean like with spinach or with
um brussels sprouts or something like
that like why on earth would you boil
them because they taste like
ass they do not but you know what i mean
don't
don't when you can when you can roast
them and they're
delicious i'm just saying they're good
either way
i kind of prefer them boiled though if i
was just going to eat them
like if you gave me a chance well that's
okay if you gave me a selection between
a bowl of roasted peanuts
even if they were roasted and had that
damn honey glaze on them
if you give me a choice of that you
never come up
if you give me choices between that and
a bowl of
hot boiled peanuts
boiled in crab boil or with or maybe uh
cayenne pepper something they were hot
real spicy i'd take that
yeah but that's yeah it's funny
weirdo weird if the seasoning's real hot
it starts to seep into your fingertips
your fingertips start burning
after a while i'm just sitting there
shelling those things it's the food that
punishes oh yeah it's just burning
it's like been sprayed with pepper spray
[Laughter]
i don't know they're so mushy though
mushy is not
i know but mushy to me does not uh
connote if they're made
if they're mushy they're they're
overcooked
i don't know the ones i had were mushy
they're overcooked then
they just snap and pop you eat them and
they kind of pop
like a real nice pinto bean or something
no a little bit harder
a little bit harder no no no you know
what they're like like a chickpea
yeah consist consistency of a chickpea
that's what they should be but they
should taste like peanuts with some
seasoning
yeah that's the few times i've had it
that's not what they tasted like
good ones my dad could cook a [ __ ] out
of boil the [ __ ] out of people i'm still
not but like i said i'm still
getting fresh peanuts on the with with
the still on the roots and everything
with the leaves and on top of it and
dirt
put them in the sink and spray them all
off make sure they got all the dirt off
of them and then you just uh
boil them yeah cut all the greens off of
them put them in a bag
or a ziploc bag or you know and have
that in the crab boil
you put them in there it's different
times though you know what i mean
because yeah crab and shrimp you know it
boils instantly yeah
potatoes yeah potatoes and corn takes
forever
so you're boiling things at different
times and you don't have time to scoop
all that [ __ ] out so you just put it in
a zip in a
in a burlap bag you know
or a net if you have that
all right fair enough yeah mr roboto
asked uh in an island of dr moreau's
situation
if perfected which animal do you become
that's an interesting question island of
dr moreau you know where he was like
making all of
it like a mega animal human hybrid yeah
the cat
probably i think i would like to be part
owl no
no you want to be part cat like a
leopard
well i mean if i'm reincarnated i
totally want to be a cat yeah because
man they just get to nap all day long
and that's pretty rad
i totally want to do that yeah zach says
i'm currently eating a chunky peanut
butter that has the oil in it straight
from the jar because i'm classy like
that
tell uh tell them what you made for
lunch today
i forgot what i made for lunch today we
just ate it like 20 minutes ago
yeah i just made a rice dish with the
sausage in it it was kind of like a
modified jambalaya
kind of like kind of like a like a like
a spanish jambalaya
yeah it's like sausage black beans black
beans
jalapenos jalapenos but um i used a
cilantro cooking base in there some um
was it uh chicken broth
georgia georgia sausage just sliced them
up pretty thin pre-cooked all that stuff
in a pan
and all the and then i had uh
even had rotel in there
and then i used uh yeah that's good i
used um
that indian royal rice that uh basmati
rice that's what i used
i i have all that cardboard rice but i
didn't i'm not getting i'm not real
confident with that [ __ ] the last time i
cooked it turned into damn glue
i don't know what's wrong with that rice
i gotta [ __ ] do some rice cooking on
its own
i tried to cook a bunch of it at once
and it didn't work out right
it makes it easy for that to go mushy
yeah it went real mushy i'm thinking
that that rice
had been had to be rinsed real well
before used
i think maybe supposed to be rinsed i
got to read the instructions on the bag
of that rice
yeah because we don't usually make the
parboil kind we usually make like
you know because we're usually like an
indian food or asian food so
i'm picky about rice but i have a big
old bag of that bam par boiled rice
because it was so [ __ ] cheap
was that uncle ben's no it's just a uh
yeah it was no it was a sam's brand that
was boiled rice
it was like a 25 pound bag of rice i
think i got for five dollars
so how am i gonna [ __ ] say no but the
thing is is that it might have not been
very good quality rice but that's why
they only wanted five but thing is the
sam's brand's usually pretty good
yeah i mean usually when you get their
brands right because we get their brands
of a lot of stuff and it's
yeah i think it just needed to be rich
and i went and i didn't rinse it
well that's probably well let's see
that's you need to read the instructions
i know dudes are not big on reading
instructions because you think you
already know everything
see that song but yeah women want to
chat
we don't want a child a [ __ ] i
want to chat
[ __ ] that's what i'm doing i'm
trying to
oh [ __ ] god
zach says uh i think jambalaya is my
favorite dish
that are my roommate's breakfast
sandwiches man there's nothing like a
good breakfast sandwiches
yeah i have too many favorite dishes to
you know
to even like i don't i don't even i
can't even think of like a favorite
cuisine
i'll eat all of it you know what i mean
obviously
there's certain kind of seafoods i don't
like uh i don't like internal organs
well yeah but it's like you know i kind
of feel like you
i don't like any kind of fish that's
that's real steaky i don't like that
[ __ ]
um like that fermented [ __ ] like they
eat up in the [ __ ] scandinavia
scandinavians don't really know anything
about food and this has been confirmed
by other scandinavians these guys will
let that damn
smelt rot in a damn [ __ ] jar and then
they [ __ ] hey let's eat it yeah let's
eat that [ __ ]
and it's just sticking to high heaven
they're eating it and [ __ ] you'll
have other scandinavians go don't eat
that [ __ ] that's just
[Laughter]
yeah firm loot fisk or lutefisk whatever
they call it yeah
that was all old school viking [ __ ]
survivalist
like you know you guys uh we have real
food now you like you guys
yeah it's a lot of stuff that people ate
just because that's all they had
do you remember i still remember this is
one of my very favorite episodes
of kitchen nightmares was that
restaurant and it was in miami of all
places
and it was a danish restaurant remember
it was called like fleming's or
something
yeah and this couple had bought it from
these old people that
died or whatever and they didn't change
anything
and it was like everything was pink
inside for one thing which was
horrifying
and it looked like i mean their whole um
you know customer base was like
old people 100 year old people that like
came in there
and since it was danish food which i
don't even like
nobody knows what that is no one really
knows what that is and it's weird
because it was like in
miami and the cook was cuban yeah and
he's sitting there going it's like
what i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm just
cooking what they tell me to cook okay
it's like i don't want to cook this crap
yeah because everything was just like
super super bland but that's like that's
why they got like all those old people
coming in there because they love that
[ __ ] they love that
they have really bad palates um
smorgasbord is [ __ ] they think oh
then that's so fancy you know it's not
fancy
flavor no not a bit of spice in it
didn't they have tin foil swans
at this place too yeah they had like if
you got like some
particular dish they'd make like a tin
foil what was funny is that
is like uh um
i think the restaurant was from the 80s
the late 80s but it was retro even in
the late 80s
yeah it was harkening back to the 60s
yeah
all right when things like smorgasbord
was in a wild exotic [ __ ] idea
oh my god that was super flavorful
swedish food
god i mean exotic flavorful norwegian
food and [ __ ]
and that was something that maybe white
people in the 60s might believe a modern
white people would not believe that that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] exotic nor flavorful
yeah not today [ __ ] no but back in the
old days paprika
was spicy oh that's too hot yeah don't
put in that black pepper on there
and that's literally the way they were
which paprika doesn't even like it's
good but it doesn't it
doesn't register as spicy tomato you use
enough of it
hungarian paprikash they use a lot of it
and it can be hot as it can be as hot as
chili
um i've seen them i've seen
i've seen um hungarians laughing at
american
uh uh paprika recipes going oh
they're mild yeah they go no no no no
you can see it
increased that [ __ ] paprika by about
10 times
you know that's how much there is all
the just put all in there
they said it should be as hot as
american chili you know that's what it
should be
but my grandparents our grandparents
uh generation and beyond were not spice
uh they were they were not familiar with
spices they didn't use them
they came from the great depression they
didn't have spices in the great
depression
yes you just didn't even have to eat
what you had and the only people that
had spice
pre-great depression would have been in
the south and that had been you know
cajuns and creole and certain people in
the south eats
the stuff um all your spices were
[ __ ]
south you know and down into mexico too
they had them
it probably got into places like
louisiana mississippi alabama
by way of texas you know that's probably
how
how the deep south got it
but now northerners and europeans didn't
eat they had
poor pallets very poor no no
seasoning dumb the bomb brought up back
in the day brought up swedish meatballs
i agree sweetheart
swedish meatballs are delicious actually
actually we make that uh
quite often yeah the thing is those you
want makes you wonder how authentic that
is
and it's just a meatball it's not spicy
it's very creamy and mild you know what
i mean the main flavor in there
is really um nutmeg yeah well that's
what i like about it i like that nutmeg
kind of flavor it's better if you use
allspice instead of nutmeg
it's even better you know but um and you
serve it with uh
well they're gonna put a lingenberry jam
yeah they're gonna
you know traditionally they're gonna put
it on [ __ ] like bow tie noodles or
some kind of
i don't like it like that i like it
better in mashed potatoes yeah i do too
or on rice
because uh i don't like those little
noodles
they don't even smell good when they're
cooked those little egg noodles
now see i do like egg noodles i do like
egg noodles
but i can have it either way i like it
with egg noodles or with mashed potatoes
that's fine with me
but back to that back to that restaurant
that gordon was messing with
they're in a [ __ ] tropical
environment surrounded by all these
[ __ ] ultra cool [ __ ]
restaurants selling [ __ ]
i get what my grandparents would have
called ethnic food but we call just
regular american food today you know
because
yeah a lot of it was just kind of like i
couldn't even tell what a lot of it was
it just seemed like the fish and chips
place
fish and chips place there was a cuban
place
near it wasn't there yeah i can't
remember i was no i was trying to think
of what they sold
what they who fleming's oh flaming
explaining so [ __ ] [ __ ]
well that's what i'm saying i was trying
to think of like some of the dishes that
they had yeah everything was like just
really
bland boy potatoes boiled carrots uh
[ __ ] some spinach
uh [ __ ] you know like [ __ ] blood
spinach
just kind of like they had toast uh they
had some kind of like meatball or
meatloaf type of thing but it looked
like there wasn't really
any spice in it yeah no it's like
something you'd get on a [ __ ]
you know like oh let's get fancy and eat
some of this potatoes like rotten
you know it was just real generic
generic [ __ ] flavorless [ __ ]
it was all some kind of good gloopy
creamy stodgy
and uh
[ __ ] gordon was in there and he goes
is this flemish is this stuck in
norwegian food
yeah it's supposed to be dangerous yeah
danish what is this
like i don't know what this is i don't
know this is so it might not even have
been authentic
yeah it was just something that's just
what they were calling it
and i think what that what it was is it
was fake american
scandinavian concepts from the 60s
that had i think that's probably what it
was more than yeah
i mean the good old days is what they
want to call them of the american 1960s
when it came to food it was nothing but
fakery
i mean it was fake fake [ __ ] everything
was fake
you know the only thing that wasn't fake
would have been paul perdom [ __ ] and
that was kind of fake
that cajun food's fake paul perdom came
up with that
he was from from louisiana but that's
not what cajun food was
cajun food was kind of like that but a
lot more primitive
it was just something you cooked in your
house this is a generic southern food
it was just in the half shell yeah yeah
so a lot of stuff a lot of stuff about
american cuisine is not that old
um they were doing [ __ ] in the 60s like
aspic
it was like what the [ __ ] why are you
making clear gelatins and putting meat
in it
knock that off [ __ ] oh my god you
couldn't get fresh stuff
everything was canned if it was fresh it
was kind of expensive and it was always
seasonal
so it was never around when you needed
it or wanted it
um meat what i think was better i
remember meeting the 70s
and in the 80s here in the united states
being cheaper and better
not all the time but i remember it being
really good and more plentiful
i also remember there being a lot more
mozzarella cheese everywhere
she went to a pizza place it had real
buffalo mozzarella on it would stretch
yeah you know that some things weren't
cheapened
uh but other things were just wrong you
know a lot of wrong stuff
think how wrong [ __ ] denny's food was
of the 80s
[Laughter]
everything was some kind of [ __ ]
stodgy [ __ ] gloopy
[ __ ] there was nothing light or
fresh or crispy or
you know it's just or spicy or spicy
yeah and that's just that's the way that
fleming's place was so [ __ ] gordon
goes in there and just goes now [ __ ]
this it throws all that food out and
turned it into a dab
because you got a cuban you got a cuban
staff a cuban chef let him cook
cuban food and he just came up with a
[ __ ] killer ass menu that just flew
out of the [ __ ] door
it flew out of there if that place is
still around that was a that was an old
episode yeah
that was an old episode yeah they tore
all that [ __ ] fake swedish [ __ ] off
the front of the front of the house
the whole thing was pink the inside
everything was pink the walls were pink
the
[ __ ] tablecloths were pink doilies
and
[ __ ] crap doilies and all those
little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little
little
little
little
little little little thing it was like
grandma's house threw up in there yeah
there's all this grandmama stuff
everywhere
and it was grandmama [ __ ] from the 80s
that's what i mean that was grandma [ __ ]
like when way back like
from when i was a kid and this was like
in the 2000s
and they're still like what are just
like we we don't know like even the
woman that owned it i think she said
what are we going to do like when all
the blue hairs died i think she got
blue hairs yeah that was blue hairs and
it was uh and
if you decorate a restaurant like that
and sell that black ass food
you'll just [ __ ] attract generations
and generations of old people after old
people after old people just recycle it
and you're only going to have them for a
couple years before they die but it's a
constant rotation of them and they don't
have much money and they're going to
come in there with a two-for-one special
that's a coupon
not tip and do all the stupid [ __ ] like
that one that was in the uk that was
just what was that the priory
that's right it was like that that one
was kind of the same thing because they
had like the
the buffet yeah and like joint
[Laughter]
every time we see that episode i've
watched that episode like so many times
and that was so funny because they took
it over it was a beautiful restaurant so
it was like inside like a decommissioned
church or whatever decommissioned i
don't know if that's what they call it
but um so it had like beautiful stained
glass windows and stuff but
they had like the buffet and the sunday
you know they had the carvery
and their big thing was that they would
have two for one
meals like you'd bring in the [ __ ]
coupon and like two people could eat and
you know what i mean so like every
sunday it'd be packed with just like
100 year old people eating for like five
bucks or something like that like eating
as much food as they wanted for
these like this is just not a recipe for
business success like giving away that
much [ __ ] food so you know what mr
roboto said
thank you mr roboto tom's thoughts on
southern vegan grits and eateries
uh i don't i i'm not aware of any kind
of vegan grits
or or southern vegan food that's that's
i've only eaten at a vegan restaurant
once my entire life i'm not like averse
to vegan food really because someone
had some that was okay but it's like
i've ever only i've only ever been to a
vegan restaurant like one time in my
whole life
and it was fine like the food was good
well you could make
vegan grits you could make them
the way the way chantal makes them
instead of butter she used them
coconut milk that's [ __ ] really good
really yeah they're really nice and
creamy yeah
we're giving away why would you buy why
would you but why would you not
put pork along with that why would you
not
why would you not do it put shrimp in
there right
if you're moralizing food you're you're
already [ __ ] up
all right um
yeah but i just thought it was funny he
goes in there and just [ __ ] changes
the menu and [ __ ] lets everybody cook
the food that they want to do and then
all of a sudden all the old people ran
younger people oh no this is great food
you want a [ __ ] you want a vibrant
you want a vibrant clientele that has
money that comes in and has fun and
so you have a good environment in there
you don't want it to be like the waiting
room to have it
you know that's that way yeah it's like
you know nothing against old people but
if that's your only clientele it's not a
good business plan no because they're
not going to last that long no
so you know i hate it and then and then
eventually when they trickle away you
end up with a [ __ ] out-of-date
restaurant that has no client no living
yeah like no one will want to go there
imagine if you had a aspic restaurant
you could have done that back in the
season that have been the hippest place
ever
yeah nothing but like them fondue places
in the 70s
yeah fondue and aspect [ __ ]
ridiculous
oh my god we should totally start a
[ __ ] chain called font
[Laughter]
that would be so awesome you could do
well you could do like a total retro
i think you you could make that work you
could make that work but the food would
have to be really really good though
and you'd have to like modernize [ __ ]
because you can't get away with doing
[ __ ] like you did back then
it's just it's funny because you know
we've talked about this a lot i remember
when i was a kid
it's like you could get chinese food you
could get
you know mexican food you could get
stuff like that but it's just kind of
like most people didn't really eat it
it's like when i was growing up
pretty much all you ate was pork chops
mashed potatoes meatloaf
spaghetti that's you know what i mean
you didn't really eat a lot of
quote-unquote ethnic food and not a lot
of fresh food either
mexican food didn't go mainstream in the
united states until the late 70s
yeah that's when that's when it started
yeah yeah
i remember being a kid my dad used to
take me to a restaurant and um
a mexican restaurant right there in
carson california
it was near where um the video store
that uh oh what's his name ended up
working in hugh tarantino tarantino
quentin tarantino worked in a video
store near there it was called
wasn't called el ranchitos that was
another one el ranchitos was a bigger
place
i think it was just i think this just
called the cantina something or other
and it was a small kind of like a diner
it was it was at one time an american
diner they got converted into a little
mexican restaurant
and man [ __ ] the food there was
[ __ ] good it was good
and my dad would be like one of the few
white guys that would go in there
it's all mexican yeah because you know
[ __ ]
this is in the 70s now you know early to
mid 70s i was a little kid
people kind of ate within their ethnic
group you know what i mean like hold on
you don't really trust that damn mexican
food there's no telling what's in it it
wasn't mainstream
yeah i remember well i even remember
when i was a kid like my dad and my
grandpa would be like we can't eat the
chinese restaurant
it's cats we don't know what they put in
it yeah i don't know what it is whatever
a lot of it was
a lot of it was the intimidation that
you opened the menu you don't really
know what and you don't know what it is
even though it's not really that weird i
mean you know it was back then i guess
so
because a lot of times the next the the
the menu was not in english it was in
spanish yeah so you're like what is this
and
the waitress would would i think part of
it is that the
uh there was a cute mexican waitress
working there i think it's part of the
reason why my daddy is
and she'd tell them what it was oh the
secret comes out yeah
and she'd tell them what it was and feel
like and just yeah give me that
so he's getting big wet burritos with
the [ __ ]
sometimes it'd be the green tomato sauce
on there sometimes it'd be the red salsa
on it
or the tacos and stuff you know the corn
tacos and flour
little flautas and [ __ ] all different
kinds of [ __ ]
that was the first time that was the
first time i ever saw nachos my dad was
asking about nachos didn't know what
they were they made nachos for them
how funny yeah it's just funny nowadays
because it's like you better
because what is nachos
[Laughter]
what is nachos that's a good idea yeah
that's a good idea it is a good idea
it's a very good idea
and what was funny what was funny about
nachos from what i remembered it was
just a plate of
tortilla chips with jalapenos on it
and i think it had i think it had the
bean burrito um stuffing on the bottom
of the plate and the cheese if i
remember correctly was just
that regular nacho cheese like a kid
comes in a can i think that's what it
was pour it on it yeah
it wasn't any kind of special cheese it
was like uh
like that [ __ ] like wait wait like
that whey protein
yeah like the [ __ ] that comes gonna get
like old el paso or
el paso it was like something you got at
the theater yeah
and it was like it comes out of the
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like that
which has its own charm yeah and that
was a mexican restaurant in a california
mexican restaurant well you could get
away with it back then yeah
you wouldn't be able to get away with
that no but i think it had that on it
because they're revealed
it's been a long time yeah uh but they
gave you big old bowls of salsa
and they were different colors and my
dad got god that's hot
god that's hot and he'd keep eating more
of it oh this is good it's hot
yeah my dad loved mexican food that's
really funny yeah and the help
cheetos was even bigger that was like a
that was like a um
that was like going to mexico it looked
like you were in a damn big old [ __ ]
had a
real high roof on it if i remember
correctly had fans and they had all them
down
paintings all those banditos and all
those like mexican bandits and [ __ ]
going around
[Laughter]
yeah and everybody spoke spanish that
was a good one back in the 70s
i don't know i don't even know if it's
there anymore probably not yeah it's
called
ranchitos um zac asked what's the
grossest place we've ever eaten
hmm i can't really think of eating
anywhere doesn't
really have gross blood it was super
super gross if if it was it was a long
time ago and i don't remember it i don't
remember particularly ever eating
anywhere and go and be like [ __ ] that
please i'll never eat there ever again
i mean i've eaten places you know like
chain restaurants and stuff where i was
just kind of like eh
that was edible you know what i mean
yeah there's like that but it wasn't bad
it just wasn't anything special so i
can't really think of any like really
disgusting places i've been
so i guess i've been kind of lucky in
that regard yeah i mean and growing up
we didn't really i mean we didn't have a
lot of money so we didn't really eat out
a lot
you know it was kind of like a big
special treat you know to go to
mcdonald's or get a
order pizza or something like that
silver grimson you love new orleans we
didn't like the food
you know what's funny is that um if you
go down to the french quarter
most of those most of those little
restaurants owned in the french quarter
are not owned by by people from
louisiana you have these [ __ ] dudes
from new york moving down there all
right
and not really knowing what
new orleans food is supposed to taste
like what louisiana food actually
supposed to taste like
and they're hiring random [ __ ]
that they don't really control
or can't really control and have them in
the kitchen working back there
just and and then you did an
investigation and those dudes cooking
aren't from there
or they're not even cooks and they just
[ __ ]
pump out some [ __ ] to [ __ ]
tourists you know
the french quarter is a tourist trap if
you want real
if you want real [ __ ] new orleans
food you gotta go to somebody's house
there might be a few restaurants out
there but you'd have to vet them
yourself
you know just showing up to the french
quarter doesn't
guarantee that you're going to get
[ __ ] authentic food or any or good
food
well anywhere that caters to mostly
tourists
is going to be hit or miss hit or miss
and a lot of guys run owning those
like i said the people owning those
businesses a lot of time are not even
from there
yeah yeah yeah he said he didn't really
he didn't like hot food
so a lot of like stuff is real spicy
honestly i don't mind a little bit spicy
but if it's too spicy i can't eat it
it'll just like give me horrible
heartburn
so you know i never really super liked a
very spicy food growing up yeah it's
just i don't
i don't like if it's so spicy that i
can't taste the food anymore where it's
all you can taste is hot
i can't right i can't really do that
most of that so-called cajun food is not
cajun food
cajun is just country creole really and
the creole stuff was a long time in the
past and
under a different [ __ ] environment
not much of that culture survives
anymore other than the people in that
area that remember it through their
family
the cuisine is kind of lost it wouldn't
be something that
would be real popular today most of it
mostly what people are calling cajun
food is something that came from paul
perdom that's 1960s
70s around that time and then
modifications upon that
upon things that pradome did like taking
that same style and kind of move it so
it's contemporary
i guess god it's not real traditional or
old or anything
there's um there's a guy
there's a there's there's a guy who's
called the [ __ ] k uh the cooking
cajun his name was justin wilson
all right i gained a guarantee
[Laughter]
and justin wilson would be on pbs all
the time and i grew up watching him
cooking he was actually one of the first
people to teach me how to cook i always
used to watch him all the time he was
kind of like the bob ross of cooking
he'd sit there and he
he's this old [ __ ] cracker all right
with this [ __ ] little thing on look
like [ __ ]
it's like a cajun cracker all right
you'll see what i'm talking about
and he would tell jokes in the middle of
his [ __ ] cooking
and cook up stuff and then and he had
kind of a
fake cajun accent he wasn't 100
authentic really
okay but he was at least having fun yeah
he'd always go
oh
[Laughter]
a little bit of wine we put a little bit
more wine
[Laughter]
you take a drink of it
and all this stuff's on youtube you can
watch it just go to cooking cage and
justin wilson he'll come up and just
watch him
yeah i used to watch him all the time he
shows about 25 minutes to 30 minutes
because there were no commercials on
on pbs he was public broadcasting and it
was only for the south
the rest of the country didn't get it if
you were lucky if you did
but the food that he's cooking really
that's cajun
slash southern cooking
that's basically what they cooked and
it's not that exotic we're going to make
potatoes potatoes our garden
and then this is fancy fresh french
style potatoes he's going to
tell you a whole story about it and then
he's going to tell you a story about
who did this and then it's all [ __ ]
it's all made up and then it ends with
some kind of a punch line and then you
feel like an idiot for listening to
funny cooking cajun go check him out
tila would love the cooking cajun
he's [ __ ] funny and the older he got
the more ridiculous he got
well you know yeah as do we all started
black and white and then went kind of
color
i like i mostly liked the ones that were
cut of color and you know colorized they
weren't that old
or you know and it's just funny fun
telling you funny [ __ ] stories and
[ __ ]
brian asked me if i had anything good to
eat in saint augustine every pretty much
everything i had there was good
i think probably the best meal i had was
at a place called
um pazalli's and it's like an italian
steakhouse type place yeah and i had
like a really really nice
like filet and man that was really
really good
and what he knows if she's he knows him
yeah she likes them a lot yeah he knows
and um there's a place there called the
saint augustine seafood company too and
they do like a really good fish and
chips like the fish is like super super
fresh like you can tell that it just
came off the boat like that morning
and then they fried it and that's really
good too they have like they have a
sit-down restaurant and they have like a
like a walk-in like counter service like
farther down the street
but yeah pretty well pretty much
everywhere i ate there was good tammy
said he came on her pbs station i don't
know where that is
i don't know if you were in the south or
not my understanding that he was mostly
on the set
on the southern ones if you could get
him outside the south you were pretty
lucky because some pbs stations were up
north and they did like him they didn't
they didn't have anything to put in that
slot so they
put him there but it was mostly the
south and if you see what he's cooking
that's actually more traditional
stuff that southerners cooked from
my dad's generation my grandparents kind
of
like my dad's generation and it's
because the grandparents generation was
even worse but you know
you'll see you'll see what it is it's
all real familiar you're like oh yeah
yeah i remember that one you know
a lot of sometimes it's stuff you
haven't had in a long time you know
but it's all very basic not real spicy
most of it most of it she says middle of
pennsylvania in the 80s
okay yeah you were lucky to get it up
that up that high north
it was mostly south remember that other
guy they used to have on there the
frugal gourmet
yeah yeah i thought was he from i kind
of feel like he was either from maine or
was he pacific northwest i can't
remember but we had him as well
and there was another thing his name was
called yan can cook oh my god i used to
love him
i think most of the country got martin
yan yeah most of the country got him
most
dude was super entertaining most of the
country got um
um bob ross yeah everybody knows
the thing about be pbs that i liked
about the old pbs this is in a time
there was no internet [ __ ] cable
wasn't
most people had cable but some places
you couldn't get cable
or it was still kind of expensive pbs
was the only way to escape commercials
it was very very relaxing you could sit
there and it was just a slow
show that didn't have any commercials
and it and it didn't have the [ __ ]
those crazy ass edits yeah everything
was super chill
everything was super i think it's the
reason now that like a lot of people
that like cooking shows
watch like the great british bake off
and stuff because it's just like a chill
because american cooking shows seem to
be like wait wait wait wait wait i'm
like in your face like all the time and
it's like i can't really stand that
either
right um so i can see why a lot of
people just kind of want to watch the
more chill ones but like you said
they're
i mean everything that was on pbs back
in the day was just like so
i mean mr rogers and all that kind of
stuff you had um
i used to like that one show what the
[ __ ] was it called his name was john
something
it was called book bird yeah and he
would um
they would take like books it was y a
novel so it was like for you know
teenagers or tweens and um he would take
a book and he would illustrate
like they would read some of the
sections of the book and then he would
like illustrate them yeah
and it's like i used to love that [ __ ]
yeah people in the comment section is
talking about justin wilson and [ __ ]
and other people on pbs bob ross and
they were saying that
one guy commented on a justin wilson
video that
as a young boy justin wilson got him
through
his life because he he was from a real
abusive
violent family and that this was the
only friendly person he
ever saw oh that's that weird that
for a while well yeah this is that the
only kind of friendly personality
everybody else was [ __ ]
was hostile hostile yeah holy [ __ ] think
of that
well that's kind of what i mean when you
think about it it's like you know you
can write stuff like that's just
entertainment like that off but you
don't know like how much
like you said how much that means to a
person yeah every day he was just
waiting to see
the [ __ ] cooking cajun because he was
just in a hostile environment because he
was such a nice man
yeah he did seem like a really nice man
see he's not still alive is he
no he's no he can't he can't be so i was
like yeah he was pretty old back then
when i saw him in the early 80s but yeah
i'd totally forgotten about yanking cook
until you said that that dude was funny
too
he might i don't know he was younger
back then but i don't think he's still
around either because that was like kind
of a long time ago
tila said he might have been from san
francisco brian said the frugal grower
maybe was arrested for molesting like
six or seven young boys i know
oh was he really i never did i didn't
hear about that yeah
i hadn't really i mean i watched that
sometimes when i was a kid but i
he wasn't as he wasn't as cool as uh he
wasn't as cool as justin
was like some of the other shows
and then julia child was on there too
yeah although that was slightly before
my time i think
yeah i don't remember all those pbs
shows that they used to have
remember that one where they had the
family it was kind of like it was almost
kind of like um
early reality tv yeah where they had
this family and they lived what was it
called 1800s house
and they took a modern family and like
made them live well they didn't make
them
that you know obviously they wanted to
but they had to live like an 1800s
family like little house in the prairies
so
that was like pretty good too yeah
they're talking about uh
yeah you can't cook i i like the ad can
cook yeah he came on a little bit later
i think i must have been about 16 or 17
i think when he started coming on
in pbs in the south and i think he
he put on he came on right after justin
wilson or right before
i liked him too he was [ __ ] he was
good he was real entertaining
chinese american guy and he'd [ __ ]
cook all kinds of stuff i think it
wasn't chinese food all the time
either it was it was american food with
a chinese
it might have been i can't i'm sure i
remember it mostly being chinese food
but i might not have seen them all
but i i think it was fusion chinese
american food yeah maybe it was
if i remember correctly the stuff that
you chinese stuff that you can make at
home just with
regular regular [ __ ] uh
easily easily sourced american
components which most of it is
you know cornstarch to ketchup vinegar
you know rice wine vinegar
how to make an egg noodle that kind of
stuff tammy said there's a youtube
channel called you suck at cooking
which is really funny yeah
i might have to like check that out i
don't watch i should watch more like
cooking
stuff on youtube i just like i'd never
get around to it yeah i i stumbled into
justin wilson a couple days back was
watching yeah
yeah it was good to see him after a
while yeah no i don't
know now i kind of want to watch
something yeah oh yeah it'll bring back
my childhood
memories oh my god yeah all right so
shut it down yeah because i'm getting
kind of sleepy yeah and actually i kind
of want some more of that rice
i just had like a little bowl yeah it's
like a half hour before we started and i
said i'll get a little bit more in a
little while because that was the first
thing i'd eaten all day and i was like
really hungry
but yeah so uh we'll be back tomorrow
afternoon
3 p.m eastern standard time we'll
probably talk about a movie or
i don't know what we'll talk about like
i said we didn't have anything to talk
about today and we went on for more than
an hour so you know yeah
there we go but yeah thanks everybody
for dropping by
have a good rest of your weekend and we
will see you guys
again tomorrow